so chapter 20 is is looking at Jews and
Catholics in the early colonies and how
do they get there what were their lives
my husband worship how do they fit in
like your book points out the American
consciousness you know sort of if you
look at American literature America
conceived of itself is not only a
Christian nation the Protestant nation
for a very long time this book
Protestant Catholic Jew comes out in the
1950s and that's that sort of assignment
by then Catholics and Jews were accepted
as part of what we alicious studies
often call the consensus of American
religious denominations some people are
sort of in the the consensus the big
broad mainstream and then there's still
some people outside of the consensus and
part of the American story has been
people who are originally outside of the
consensus making their way in being
accepted having an having a place so
originally you know the Protestants are
the ones who are really running the show
if you're in Massachusetts it's not just
all the Protestants it's the Puritans if
you're not a Puritan in Massachusetts
around 1700 you're in a lot of trouble
you know if you're in the southern
states the top people are the
Episcopalians at that time the Anglican
not that it's working around on Baptists
we're kind of frowned up over time these
groups get get assimilated but it's one
thing to bring in you you know other
process it's another to bring in
Catholics and Jews where there's large
or differences between them and the
other Protestants so your book doesn't
talk as much about about Jewish life but
let's let's start with that because in
many respects it's it's easier to to
tackle jus start coming over to the
United States before it's the United
States
fairly like your book points out when
this is still where we are right now do
the Amsterdam there are Jewish colonists
coming in and settling so the
association between American Judaism and
New York goes back very long ways and
remember when we talked about the two
different main groups with the the Jews
who were in Mediterranean area the
Sephardic and then the ones who are in
Germany and Russia the ones in Germany
and Russia and Lithuania and places like
that they're not emigrating over the
United States as quickly as the ones who
are in the other areas which which are
actually in some respect Latin speaking
areas and your book talks about
congregations being organized in with
your newport rhode island savannah
philadelphia charleston what we'll all
these have in common they're all major
cities and what else do we have in
common do you think about your geography
of good restaurants that's not that's
not a very looking at all ports right
they're all important areas of Commerce
that's what the population is coming for
in part and also because it was a refuge
there's a place here we go there was a
lot of persecution in Europe at that
time so your book has this nice
discussion at the very end of this
chapter about Sephardic Jews stopping
speaking there there Ladino and and
becoming sort of assimilated fitting in
and it talks about this synagogue the
touro synagogue which you can you can
still go to today in the newport rhode
island and you can't tell by looking at
the outside that it's a Jewish building
as opposed to many other synagogues
where there's a sort of distinctive
style to it it's blending in it fits in
you go inside and now it has all the
things that the synagogue is supposed to
have and so your book talks about this
as being neoclassical and style and
what's it the message there the message
is that it's a prosperous and
sophisticated congregation desiring a
tasteful and commodious place for
worship but not wishing to attract undue
attention to its presence by anything
which may seem indecorous where it is on
so one thing you can say about Judaism
in early colonies is that it's a matter
of blending into the culture letting
into the culture Wow retaining Jewish
culture Jewish culture and religion can
you say the same thing about Catholics
who are the first Catholics that to come
to the United States and Ashley 7 I know
Spanish you know with Columbus but they
didn't actually stick around you know
they voted in they voted out who are the
what's the first major kappa presence
here in north america besides the
spanish rings we're going to look at it
another time it's not the Irish because
they come later who is it I'll give you
a hint they still don't like the English
today don't turn to ring any bells you
complain about them bring ya friendship
a long history of complaining of that
English or American oppression and the
French settle Indian you know what's
nowadays Quebec the Maritime Provinces
also in a lot of you know New England
there's a heavy French presence even
today
northern New Hampshire in northern
Vermont and where else in the United
States what's going to become the United
States one other place its gurus
distinctively French every forgiving him
it's a state that he has parishes
instead of counties yeah Louisiana yeah
Louisiana in part because of New Orleans
and then in part because of what's
essentially some ethnic cleansing that
takes place where they force the
Acadians out of acadia down into
Louisiana where they become the cages
now they're all going to be Catholic
know how Catholic are they you know they
kind of vary some people are more devout
some people lust about but the French
are really key in the French are really
key in early American Catholicism so you
get the French up in what's now adays
Quebec and New England how can they be
into England while the Puritans are
there well the Puritans are in the south
and the French are in a way up in the
north the parts that are enjoying back
without Louisiana 200 is weezy oh we're
all sir Catholics coming in early on in
part Marilyn man we're talking about
English Catholics in large part Maryland
is originally established as a place
where Catholics can be tolerated because
at the time you know the Puritans are
going to allow Catholics in there
they're actually against the Church of
England because the Church of England is
still to Catholic for them right so they
don't want any of these these Roman asst
coming in it's bad enough that they're
up there
in Canada while I love them come into
your colonies you're just asking for
trouble and then some of the other
colonies as well not enough Pennsylvania
of course because there was religious
tolerance there but some of the other
colonies didn't allow Catholics to come
in or they didn't allow them to vote or
there were other things that they could
you know essentially make you a
second-class citizen marilyn is
establish specifically to be a refuge
for Catholics now can they just say all
Oh it'll be a refuge for count that's
just Catholics can come there that's not
going to fly right because we're still
very strong anti-catholic sentiment in
the English colonies so they had to
allow toleration to everybody and
eventually it's overturned and Catholics
actually wind up losing some of these
rights for a while in Maryland but for
quite a while English Catholics can come
to maryland and many other english
people as well you don't fit into the
religious establishment and go to
maryland now who are the big immigrant
populations that are that are going to
be Catholic after the French after the
English yeah dyers yeah Irish
immigration is being very important and
they're going to be influenced by and
also sort of rivals to the French the
first bishop is in Quebec or not is it
Montreal or Quebec in the province of
Quebec the second bishop is going to be
in Baltimore and that's seen your book
doesn't actually mention that but that's
seen in part as a bit of a victory for
the Irish because now it's not just the
French running the show eventually you
know Catholicism has all these ethnic
components to it people want to have
their own representation and they
and they fit in who else are going to be
important if we move ahead a little bit
a little bit out of this chapter who
also do some really important
ethnicities associated with Catholicism
to think about heavily Catholic areas
like Long Island and what do they
downloaded ethnicities or what else is
heavily Catholic New England that these
days yeah so they're going to this is
this is actually sort of getting a
little bit ahead of us but it was going
to be Italian immigration where else are
Catholics coming from not coming from
Russia or agrees because those are
Orthodox right they're not coming from
Scotland as those are Presbyterians
where else where else do the Catholic
nationalities come from a few major
spots my mom grew up in Chicago after
every nationality has its own church and
they beat you up if you want it to their
neighborhoods Your Honor if you weren't
Irish and belonging the Irish
neighborhood Germans polish we're going
to get to those we want to focus mainly
on the fraction and the the Irish and
the English as well your book talks
about the the effect of the French
Revolution the French Revolution they
guillotined a lot as we mentioned before
a lot of the nobility right the Anniston
ability they got rid of those class
distinctions who else was the French
Revolution directed against historic do
you remember the nobility was the first
estate the third estate was everybody
Allison than the second state was the
church the 4g French Revolution was
intensely anti-clerical it's a lot of
French Catholics
had to get get out of town it wasn't
safe to be Catholic especially if you're
a priest or a monk or a brother or nun
or sister a lot of those religious
orders ended up you know taking a much
greater role in in America because the
French Revolution can push them out and
then there were some orders that
actually began after the Revolution came
to America in part because the
importance of the French and then there
were some orders that actually started
here in America talks about the sisters
of charity for example that was a
distinctively American religious order
within the Catholic Church your book
also tells you a little bit about this
guy John Carroll and he's important not
just as a single figure and because he's
you know a bishop of Baltimore he's
important because he represents
something so this is sort of what we're
going to close with and it has to do
with how Catholics in America
historically are a bit different from
Catholics in other places Carol lay it
says was an enthusiastic supporter of
the new American spirit of democracy
democracy and church-state separation
the Catholic Church in Europe resisted
this very very strongly for well over a
century and ultimately ended up having
to more or less go the way that that
somebody like John Carroll want
accommodating himself to this from the
beginning here in America we tend to
look at these things as like part of our
culture right democracy we like to do
things democratically we look to the
separation of church and state no
official religion that's not that way
everywhere and that's an achievement
that took place Carol aligned himself
and thereby remind American Catholicism
to the
so you don't have the Catholic Church
trying to take over and becoming the
state or anything like that once a
Catholic population is is pretty large
Carol also liked the book pointed out
decided to make his Cathedral sort of
like that Jewish synagogue something
that would fit in so let's put down to
the word again assimilation
assimilations you the culture of fitting
in Carol is important because without
compromising being Catholic this is the
route that he is charting out for
American Catholicism you know because if
you're the bishop you have a lot of you
have a lot of power you have a lot of
capacity to set the agenda in a church
that's very high art right so that's
what we're going to close with